i'm dave rubin and we've got another
friday panel extravaganza for you today
we're going to be discussing a brand new
series launching on
locals this summer called the woke
reformation
and joining me are the filmmaker travis
brown
and two of the series contributors
friends and former guests of the reuben
report best-selling author douglas
murray
and associate professor of philosophy
at portland state university peter
bogosian guys welcome to the reuben
report
great good to be with you thank you
so my audience of course knows douglas
and pete
so travis i'm gonna let you introduce
yourself
first so first if you could just tell us
a little bit about yourself and how you
got into this project this was this was
sort of your baby
yeah yeah well i am an independent
filmmaker
in the wok capital of the world also
known as portland oregon
i'm in bed with my dog nora because i
have debilitating back pain and it keeps
me
at about 90 percent horizontal which is
difficult but i have a really fantastic
team uh many of whom i i can't name
because
for fear of backlash um which is
unfortunate but i have a fantastic team
uh including evan gandy as my
cinematographers which is why the film
looks so good but i got into it because
i i grew up in a fundamentalist
christian home
that was really really challenging and i
was indoctrinated into this belief
system
and i slowly slowly left it behind and
and then i moved to portland i actually
moved to seattle and then portland two
of the
most liberal you know progressive cities
around
and i thought i would agree more with
these people but turns out i
don't it turns out that they're very
similar
dogmas and religious like uh
belief systems that people participate
in and that that really concerned me
it mirrored my childhood and i i see
people
constantly being indoctrinated into this
woke religion
and so that that's that's what i want i
want to help people
understand this problem in particular
liberals and progressives i want them to
be aware of where the ideology came from
and and know
that it's it's divisive and harmful pete
since you're in portland how did you get
involved in all this did you guys just
bump into each other on the street and
realize oh my god there's someone else
saying here
uh no i've known travis for quite a
while he's filmed many many of my events
and
uh one of the things that's been
fascinating to me dave
is he approached me about the series
precisely because he had an experience
that neither douglas nor i have had
of having grown up in a christian-like
cult
i i'll let travis speak to the details
of that but
the parallels just seemed so ominous to
him and again
i'm i have a different view and i think
douglas has a different way of looking
at the problem
but for some from someone who's been
indoctrinated in a religious cult to see
the parallels and the similarities
and he just said i have to do something
about this it's just
it's a kind of poison that's killing
everybody and we started talking about
what those parallels were
and then he dedicated him so he devoted
himself to making the series
yeah douglas i want to let you jump in
and then we're going to throw quickly to
the two-minute trailer which is really
fantastic how did you get involved in
this project
well you know some people uh summer in
the south of france or spring in italy
and i was autumning in portland
[Laughter]
and that's how these guys got me roped
in and i have to say it was a great
pleasure
uh i was uh i was disaster tourism
in uh in uh the state uh of oregon
and uh ahead of the election around the
time of the election
and you know it's it's uh it's easy to
joke about it but as
everyone here knows we're dealing with
as travis said
fundamentalists here people who've been
indoctrinated
into a fundamentalist mindset and you
know we're we're quite good in this era
of
identifying when people are falling into
scientology or some other uh crazy sect
and
and yet the biggest uh growing sect of
our time has been going on
growing underneath us without being
identified so anyone who does identify
that and wants to push back
against that and and take that sect
apart
to deconstruct the deconstructionists as
i think of it
i'm on board and uh i have to say from
everything i've seen so far it looks
just terrific
all right well you queued me up
perfectly so let's throw to the trailer
for the woke reformation
i don't
[ __ ] care but no better than me i
wish you would white lady i wish you
would
[Music]
unfortunately a large number of people
believing their acting in the name of
justice
seem to think that you can play groups
of people against other groups in order
to win
this isn't a solution for justice it's a
solution for endless ongoing division
it's not just that it's just
spontaneously or arbitrarily pops up
there's a system in place that
manufactures these ideas
they look at the universities as their
own particular ideology mill
and they indoctrinate people into
intersectionality so a whole generation
of people
are now believing things that are
totally untethered to reality
these are people who are teaching very
dangerous ideas what makes those ideas
dangerous
is that they're divisive we start
looking at each other in terms of race
this does not advance civil rights
causes it's exactly the opposite
i have actually been fired i've been
replaced
for not toeing the line if you show up
as an authentic individual
in any way shape or form where the
woke ideology holds sway well we will
take away your ability to support
yourself we'll take away your ability to
eat will take away your ability to own
anything it's deeply dystopian it's lazy
to just like
set somebody off and say i don't care
about their life anymore and i don't
want this person to have any way back
ever if that's the modus operandi you're
going to live by
you better be careful because absolutely
this will come for you and this is being
driven by people who believe
they are doing this and acting in this
way in order to make us all freer
and they're not they're tying everyone
down they're tying us up
they're holding everybody back
[Music]
so travis what do you want the film to
accomplish is this really just about
waking up those progressives
and liberals as you're saying or or are
you trying to
really start a movement here i mean i
know that these guys have really been in
on that for a long time
yeah that's a great question um i mean i
want the
series to appeal to everyone
conservatives liberals moderates
progressives
who whoever there is there's a certain
as douglas
said uh sect that will be very angry
with me
for making this but those people are
unfortunately lost all together
my goal is to help people one understand
the origins of this stuff so i i was
lucky enough to get helen pluck rose and
james lindsey
at the beginning of the series and then
lucky enough to obviously
douglas and pete and nancy rommelman and
and my friend corey drayton who
happens to be a black filmmaker here in
portland um
to speak out against this stuff so so
the goal is to to help people understand
the origins
to help them know how divisive it is and
how people are using racism and sexism
as
political and political shields for
political power and social clout
a lot of people still don't understand
that these are just proxies and i think
people need to know that
and then i also hope um at the at the
end of the series i
offered two or three episodes that are
solutions what can people do
if they see crt being taught in the
school or
they see this this racist [ __ ] uh
you know in in their workplace you know
what what what can they do douglas
offered a lot of really great um
examples of what people can do and so
did nancy
and azra nomani actually got that in
this series too so
yeah douglas do you are you shocked
i should say are you shocked that this
so much of this has leaked across the
pond and is now
in the uk and really is pretty much
everywhere in the west at this point
it's not just in portland where these
two guys are
uh yeah that's right it has it has
leaked way beyond uh
the borders of where one might have
thought it could have stopped uh
but there are good signs that that
people are opposing it you know
just in recent weeks we've seen an
increasing pushback against it from
france uh
it's uh quite uncommon to hear somebody
with my accent praising the french but
uh
but here we go i mean uh emmanuel macron
and academics across france have been
saying no this uh
this is uh he thought
uh you know i mean france is of course
uh partly responsible for this because a
sort of form of french thought went
across to america was picked up by
maniacs
and now they're trying to export it
everywhere else but actually as i say
it's it's a source of some hope that in
france at any rate from the top of
government to you know very significant
figures and french thought they're
saying that
this doesn't this doesn't uh this
doesn't cut it
this isn't what you pretend it is it
isn't academia it isn't
thought it isn't philosophy it's
dogmatic politics
that attempts of course to bully
everyone by presenting itself as
incredibly intelligent
and intimidating people but i think i
think the more people uh uh
see other people not being intimidated
uh by it
the more they won't be intimidated by by
it themselves and and travis and peter
and you dave i mean
we all know examples of that many many
people who at first
just don't know what has happened when
this juggernaut
comes at them and of course for many
people it comes at them at their own
dinner table in their own household
with kids they've sent away to college
and they've come back stupider
and they don't know what to do when this
juggernaut comes at them at first
but by now and with travis's film and
peter's work and the work of
of many other people as well people do
now know they can now know what it is
and they can know how to dodge this
juggernaut and even maybe turn it round
pete i was just watching the alien
movies i watched four of the alien
movies this weekend
there's a there's a moment in the
original alien movie where the science
officer who who ends up being an android
but he basically is talking about
the elegance and how much he admires the
alien because it just takes over the
host and it's merciless
and it knows what it's doing and it
doesn't have remorse or a conscience or
anything else
and as i'm watching it i'm thinking that
sounds kind of similar to something
going on right now
do you do you sort of admire the way
this thing has
spread not because you respect it but
because it's been so effective
in doing what it's tried to set out to
accomplish i i would suppose i'd admire
it in the way i'd admire any ghastly
grotesque spectacle
that that is so deranged that it
really separates itself from the norms
of human rationality and morality
so in that sense yeah i i guess i do
what was
i remember that that uh scene i love the
the alien films um
one of the things that that strikes me
about this and i think it's
very important to know is like the alien
this
is destroys everything it touches
anything it contacts
forget it it's over and you have to have
a zero tolerance policy
it is a universal solvent that there is
no institution no matter how
hall venerable that will not be
destroyed
there's no individual once it seeps into
their cognitions
and douglas and i talk in travis's film
about how that takes place through the
words through equity diversity inclusion
and so yes it is a universal solvent i
guess i admire it they've had 40 years
to work on it and like douglas said
helen puck rose is a wonderful piece in
aerial magazine
ar eo i think the title is how french
intellectuals rule in the west
so they've had many many decades of
working on
the language of of really
i think one of the ways to think about
it again back to the alien parallel
we think of of evolution as a biological
process
but as dawkins says it's also a memetic
process
ideas evolve and this particular idea
has a kind of recalcitrance to it that
it's almost like it's like a little b
alien you stomp them out and they come
keep coming back like cockroaches
so the key thing is to just not let not
let social justice in any form
into the organization have zero
tolerance for it
and we've seen case after case after
case of the aclu the splc
the university systems and on and on and
on advertising corporations marketing
once it happens it's over
travis over yeah yeah travis to that
point did you
when you were interviewing people and
going to some of these events and
obviously in the trailer you see a lot
of the sort of hysteria around this
i mean were you shocked at the way that
just seemingly
sane 18 year olds are suddenly screaming
about things that they
basically know nothing about i don't i
don't know if shocked is the right word
given my developmental experience um
it it isn't actually surprising to be
honest
um you know this is something
uh jordan peterson talks a lot about
this desire for meaning and for
for community and unfortunately as
as pete says it's it's ghastly and it's
grotesque but it is it does offer that
right it does offer meaning
it does offer a a grand narrative a
purpose
and so uh i i think that's incredibly
important
um and that's something that that we're
largely missing and
douglas has talked about this as well
but no it's it's it's not that
surprising to me i mean
people will do anything to hold on to
whatever sense of meaning and purpose
that they have
yeah douglas do you think that's why uh
you know we've discussed this a couple
times you know i've come to the
conclusion that the conservatives
generally speaking
have a better defense mechanism because
there is more structure around their
sense of meaning
that the liberals don't necessarily have
so i guess partly do you agree with that
even though i know we've discussed it a
couple of times and do you think that
offers a better defense
well there are lots of defenses against
it one
which sounds like a critique of
conservatives and but isn't
is that conservatives are naturally more
suspicious of ideas
than leftists uh it's it's a it's a
strange paradox
in a political thought those of us who
are
more to the right often have to juggle
with this paradox
but the suspicion of ideas on the
ideological right comes about for very
good reason
it comes about i mean we read it in
edmund burke most famously
a fear of where ideas lead in politics
and this is very of course this is hard
particularly for younger people to
resist because
if somebody comes at you with a an
all-explaining
idea and says this is the great
revolution of your time
the young are disproportionately likely
to want to jump in on that because who
doesn't want to have a bit of that
action
it's only when you're older apart from
things has more experience that you can
see
well that action includes a lot of blood
a lot of crushed skulls a lot of wrecked
lives and ruined opportunities and it's
not so
cute when you look at it in the rearview
mirror so
that sort of age and youth experience i
also think is reflected in the political
debate on the left and right
that there is a suspicion of ideas and
that you see that even in the everyday
dialogue in the media and elsewhere
the right tends to say oh we we at its
best
says we don't want any of that nonsense
and combat it away
but parts of the left certainly too much
of it as peter well knows
sort of fall into the discussion it's
what peter said about the importance of
the zero tolerance strategy towards this
they they take a bit of it you know
people start talking about equity
and social justice and people slip even
into the language
when they talk about social justice
they're not talking about social justice
most of the time they just mean revenge
when they talk about racism and
anti-racism they don't mean anti-racism
they may
revenge racism by a different group of
people
and and just more and more people have
to realize that even the language has
been totally polluted so i'm with peter
you just can't take on a bits the
language you can't concede bits of it
this is a deeply uh ugly uh
ideology it despises to be totalitarian
wherever it gets a grip as in parts of
portland it wrecks everything that it
has
in its purview i hope more and more
people realize that
and i think they are realizing it yeah
by the way douglas well real quick you
know one of the reasons that i loved
douglas's last book madness of crowds is
because he makes a point of separating
the t the trans from the gay rights
movement right because they combine all
of these things and then suddenly no one
actually knows
what they're fighting for or what
they're fighting against anymore pete
good
all ahead i don't remember what i was
going to say well what i all right
i started thinking of the madness of
crowds and if you haven't read it it's a
mandatory read
so so pete i i sort of feel like you
were kind of
born to be in this fight because you're
a philosophy professor
in portland you wrote a book called a
manual for creating atheists i mean you
you try to de-program people from
bad ideas but do you think you saw all
this early just by the nature of that
that you were in the city at a college
like the city that's the craziest out of
college
that's one of the craziest and the very
thing that you study and care about is
so deeply connected to all this
yeah i think i think that was part of it
i came from the new atheist movement or
even before that i came from basic
epistemology which is
how you know what you think you know and
some of the same tools
were so striking to me the same
manifestations theo liberalism the
irrationality
the lack of cognitive liberty people
want you to think a certain way
but but let's be clear about something
i'm done playing
i think douglas is done playing uh
i'm waging full-scale ideological
warfare against the enemies of western
civilization
i am taking no prisoners i have very
large scale projects coming for the
enemies of reason
and science and rationality these people
are divisive neo-racist hate mongers
and there's simply no we we must broker
absolutely zero tolerance with with this
ideology
and the only way forward at this point
is full-scale ideological war and i will
take no prisoners and that's what i'm
devoting my life to i will
i seek the complete eradication and
extirpation of the ideology
from every facet of life likewise
but tell me how you really feel travis
travis
you must love hearing that right yeah
yeah no i mean pete peter and i are in
battle together for sure
and we have we have many projects
planned i want to be explicitly clear
about something
and pete framed it nicely but these are
ideas
that are the problem you know i mean
obviously certain people are
are bad actors but but most people like
most religious people are genuinely good
and you know that they you know they
want to do good but
it's the ideology that's the problem and
that's that's what we're fighting and
the term woke used to just mean being
awakened to injustice
you know that's not what it means
anymore at least for most people
i'm using it in the series as a
catch-all term for uh
this umbrella ideology of you know
whether it's transgender ideology
or you know anti-racism ideology
critical race theory
i'm using it as an umbrella term and i
do think we should all be
awakened to injustice but that's not
what these people are doing that's not
what this ideology accomplishes
yeah douglas what's been the best
defense that you've seen
against this well i think there's been
quite a few i i mean
individuals have cropped up in recent
years some very interesting
collection of backgrounds and an
interesting
collection of disciplines um it's
fascinating actually now
you can almost sort of chart the people
who've popped up across the globe
who have tried to point out the flaws of
this ideology
quite often it's because the ideology
has come
for them but the thing i i observe
that's the most heartening really and i
think i said this to travis and peter
uh were filming is that one thing i
found most heartening is that
there are weird people i think like all
of us
uh um there are weird people who hold on
to concepts like
truth and put a high premium on them
and not going along with lies that
they're told to go along with
and this throws up really curious people
like it throws up some very religious
people
who just from their from their their
religious teaching they just they just
don't want to
repeat lies they're told it throws up
atheists
uh there's no uh um clear sleep on that
one
it throws up people on the ideological
left and people on the ideological right
people who are
fascinated by politics and people who
never really gave a damn about politics
until this came along
so what strikes me is by now there's a
very
interesting coterie of people around the
world
of every imaginable background who just
don't like being told to lie
and will not go along with the lie and
sometimes they're teachers they crop up
around the world and this is the
interesting thing
and we saw it recently with the
manhattan school teacher
if you don't go along with it the short
term you pay an extraordinary price
but you know you're on to something
because of the extraordinary
interest that comes around you when you
start saying that you don't believe this
you see if one teacher in a school says
hang on
with being segregated along racial lines
in the school and i don't think that's a
good thing you will immediately be in
serious trouble as the manhattan school
teacher was with your boss and you might
even lose your job
paul ross you might even lose your job
in the short term as he did always i
gave he's got a job now
but and any child would be very very
lucky to be taught by him
but but the point is is that you
immediately attract all this attention
because of the number of people who
don't yet
have the guts to do it but this suggests
that the people who are doing it are on
to something
the movement is only going to grow i
don't
i'm not at all surprised at this stage
that the
candies and the d'angelos and all the
other hucksters and
foresters of the age are talking a
higher and higher
rhetoric and talking more and more
angrily why are they doing it
because they're starting to notice that
they're not
being regarded as the self-appointed
sheriffs that they think they are
they came into town and literally
announced themselves sheriff of the
entire moral landscape
and then these irritating people a
burgosian there and travis brown there
dave rubio they start to pop up and say
i don't respect your credentials you
don't have the right to be
sheriff and more and more people are
doing it they're losing their power it's
going to be ugly as they get out but
they're going to get out
you know it's funny douglas i usually
don't come to you for the pollyannish
response but you're you're giving me the
silver they're still dating
i have fought so many unwinnable battles
in my life i know an unwinnable battle
when i see one
this is a winnable battle totally i love
that
this it's inherently unsustainable so
two things
the what douglas talked about speaking
truth in the face of danger it's a
greek virtue called parahesia ironically
foucault writes about it
and that's what we need we need a
thousand paul rossi's we need a thousand
jodie shaws
and then we need a cascading effect of
people who are willing to speak out
so go to the most important thing is go
to these events
show up document make videos put
yourself out there
and if you're afraid piggybacking off of
what travis said
of compromising your relationships and
damaging your friendships
i would argue that these people weren't
your friends to begin with
aristotle talks about the highest form
of friendship is between two virtuous
people
two people who are willing to speak
about an injustice two people are
willing to speak about a truth
and so you should never have to
obfuscate or hide what you believe
or what you say you should never have to
bear false witness or confess to
something in which you don't believe
and this is exactly what these people
are telling us to do
so if if you're worried about your
friendships being so dave if you and i
have a disagreement we will talk to each
other and we've done it before and and
we would definitely and we'll be honest
with each other and we'll be forthright
with each other and then we will have
drinks
that is not the case with this with the
the people who who have been infected by
this ideology
and so the first thing that people need
is speaking truth in the face of danger
the greek virtue parahesia and the
second thing is
these people were probably not your
friends so
if you want to have authentic
relationships in your life
that has to be based upon truth well i
love that you guys are all sort of going
on the
offense here because that's what we've
needed for a long time we all were
diagnosing it
talking about it interviewing the people
about what was happening but now there
seems to be this feeling of like oh
now we can make a move travis when
you're making a documentary like this
how do you make sure
that you don't wade into propaganda that
you actually stay with something that is
true even when it's
this closely held to you that's a that's
a fair question it's a great question
um i mean when i
left christianity behind
one of the guiding lights for me was
truth
i i just i wanted to know the truth no
matter
how it made me feel excuse me
which is a scary uh proposition to put
you know
position to put yourself in it's it's
very discomforting
um but i think that's that's one way
that i navigate this
is that if i uh as a matter of fact i
was talking with peter recently and and
uh you know that
we have disagreements here and there and
i just i i have to always be honest
about it
um and i think that that's that's just
what you have to do and in terms of
propaganda um there's a story i could
tell but i won't
maybe behind the scenes i'll tell you
but uh i i fought very hard to make sure
that
this was the truth as i saw it so i i
have biases
you know i'm sure people will say it's
biased but i did my very best
uh just as i did with christianity to
examine it honestly
and just to be honest about the problem
and i want to uh
piggyback off what they said people have
to start speaking out i mean that's
i i i don't i didn't really have a horse
in this fight in the sense of
it wasn't that my school i'm independent
you know it's it's not necessarily a
problem
but when i see everyone going [ __ ]
mad around me you know
people need to stand up and and
and not put up with it anymore so
douglas if this is a winnable fight as
you said it
is what do we do after let's say we
really do get some wins and this thing
starts turning around a little bit
it seems fairly obvious to me that the
real you know the candies
and and the people that have really been
driving at d'angelo they're not going to
ever wave the white flag and say oh we
were actually wrong
about everything we said about the
nature of reality
i think some of the foot soldiers maybe
we can show them a better path out but
but what do we do about the
sort of intellectual drivers of this
thing that it's their reason
for existence like what what happens
after with them because they want to
burn it down i mean they're
telling us that that the you know that's
what they want well
yeah i mean and they are the
intellectual drivers of it and they have
a sort of pattern
of intellectualism i think they're being
found out
i think they're being seen through and
that's the most dangerous thing for any
intellectual movement like with any
politician
it's not when people dislike curious
when they see through you
and we can see through this now i made a
lot of jokes in the madness of crowds
about this about the execrable way in
which these people
write you can tell in in in the prose
that they don't really know what they're
doing because if they knew what they
were doing they wouldn't write
so badly you only write as badly as they
do when you're trying to cover over a
lie
or you don't know what you're saying so
i think the intellectual pattern is
being seen
through i don't think there's much more
left in it
i think that they are clearly the people
you describe as
intellectual drivers clearly uh working
with
an increasingly inflated currency
they have called everyone hitler now
every literally everybody is a racist
um everybody is a fascist uh they've
devalued the entire currency
uh and i don't think that they've got
much further to go on this road i think
they're in a
situation of zimbabwe and hyperinflation
with their currency
i think it's a very dangerous position
for them to be in they will continue to
wheel around their wheelbarrows
full of excrement but there is no reason
why as
years go on everybody will continue to
pay them the attention that they have
i think most people will continue to
look at them with some interest
once they've seen through they will
discard these people they will keep
going
but their thoughts will be discarded
just as surely as it only took
a a few extraordinary people like
solzhenitsyn
um to muck the whole game up for the the
the crass uh far-left marxist apologists
of totalitarianism in the late 20th
century
very few of them by the way ever
actually as peter knows very few of them
ever actually said oh okay guys the
game's up
they just slithered away they slivered
away
and that's what will happen with these
guys at some point in the future
robyn d'angelo will be writing books
still it's just no one will be reading
them
we know they're lying they know they're
lying and
they know we know they're lying that's
pretty much right there
they're like televangelists that's
exactly what they are no one cares about
televangelists anymore and that's
exactly what these people are
pete what about the institutions that
they'll leave behind i mean would you
view a place
i don't want to put you on the hot seat
at your exact university but like would
you view these places that have been so
infected
that they could ever come back even as
more people move away from this
no portland state university is a
festering ideological cesspool i
wouldn't even send a dog there
and i was trying to question you on the
spot no no
well you have to speak about it what it
is right it is an ideology mill
it is an indoctrination center and the
purpose of the
the entire institution is based upon
equity
the president has come out stephen percy
and said repeatedly
in video on email the highest priority
of the university is to address racism
the highest priority
not to educate students not academic
excellence no intellectual virtues not
even to be solvent
not even to be fiscally solvent so i
think
the university is lost we've given some
hardcore
ideologues uh we've given them jobs for
life
they're intent on indoctrinating
students they come into the classroom
with the right answers and they test
people on what those answers are
and you mark right or wrong as a
consequence of that
that leaks out into the into the broader
public in our institutions
and the problem is that the mission of
those institutions is the same like the
aclu
but the people occupying those positions
have different moral values like
i was taught civics when i was a kid and
so
as i'm 54 as younger people occupy those
institutions the values that they've
been indoctrinated with
and and that's one of the the the things
that's so destructive about this
and so hurtful uh is that they think
that they're doing good
right they think that they're basing
their beliefs on the base of evidence
because their professors told them so
but their professors are really third
rate ideologues
and as douglas says judith butler for
example she's a paragon of unclarity
like she just does not write clearly
she obfuscates and one of the things
that i think that we'll see we're
already seeing
is the new institutions academic
institutions
uh that are evolving and then are rising
up the problem is that we cannot
maintain our economic competitiveness
if the meritocracy is destroyed if our
our
colleges and universities are suspect
and already there's been a crisis of
legitimacy so there's been an erosion of
confidence in our public institutions
i don't think it's possible to get that
trust back unless we build new
institutions
that's the only way i see it here's one
other thing that i want to
stress that's so important that
if if you had a magic wand and you can
wave the wand and take the
ideology in totally totally out of k-12
systems of education the problem is that
colleges of education are entirely
predicated upon this ideology
they're literally built on paolo
ferrari's pedagogy they're pressed
jerome
they're built on critical consciousness
they're built on
ideas that are that come in a suite to
the woke ideology
so those k-12 systems would then just be
populated again
with ideologues so the root we know the
root of this problem right
so in the grievance studies affair we
tried to expose that in
cynical theories in the madness of
crowds those two books explained it
now we're in a new phase of this and the
new phase is to
solve it the new phase is ideological
warfare
the new phrase is shifting the overton
window to push these ideas into
disrepute
but part of that is we need structures
in our society we need institutions and
systems
that come up commensurate with that k-12
systems
higher colleges in education because if
we don't have that it will be impossible
to maintain our economic competitiveness
pete i got nothing better to do than
save the world so i look forward to
doing this with you travis i want to
give you the last word and then we'll
explain where people
can watch and communicate with you guys
directly
great well first i just want to say
thanks again for having me on i'm really
honored
to be on a virtual stage with all you
guys it's great
um secondly i want to touch on what you
kind of pinched out in your last
question to douglas like what what comes
after this right like what
what do we do when we've just dismantled
this the idea is not just to dismantle
and just deconstruct for no reason
there's a reason to do that and that's
to
live you know meaningful lives to to
uh enjoy friendships to explore to
travel to
make art you know there's so much to
life
so much more to life than this [ __ ]
and there are injustices that we ought
to fight but
this is not the way to fight them we
know how to fight these injustices we
learn from the civil rights
we we have the liberal values that we
need to
um to push back and to to unify so
that's
i'm that's my call to action i suppose
douglas i would be remiss if i didn't
give you the opening for a classic
douglas murray ending of an episode
no i i entirely endorsed what travis
just said
i think the point is to get these people
out of the way to
drop the friends if they want to drop
you
because of this if your friends
indoctrinated try to get rid of them
they don't want the best for you
and to get these people out of the way
get all these fraudsters and
intellectual hucksters
out of our way and there is no single
answer to what we're meant to do with
our lives after this
uh but we do know that this system is
going to be holding back
so many people it's going to be as it
already has done
it's gonna be ripping families apart
ripping friendships apart
ripping societies by ripping cities
apart
and we need to get this out of our way
to get on to what we do what should we
do almost anything else
almost anything else just not this
you'd be better off looking at a wall
can i can i add one last thing
yeah just just one last thing which is
we do need to get these people out of
the way but anyone who changes their
mind needs to be forgiven
shocked absolutely 100 very very
important point
hey we've we've got a redemption
narrative which is that we're humans and
we're flawed and i think that gets to
pete's earlier point that they don't
have that narrative they they kind of
want you to bow
forever well listen i'm thrilled to be
in this fight with you guys and i'm also
thrilled to tell everybody that this is
sort of the first
original that we're doing on locals so
if you go to
thewokereformation.locals.com
you can actually see clips of the series
already
you can communicate directly with these
guys i'm gonna be happy to help in any
way i possibly can and i'll jump in the
community as well
and uh you know you've always got an
ally in me
so travis douglas pete i thank you guys
have a great weekend
and we'll talk soon thank you thank you